for
[Silence]
subala
who for
[Silence]
subhanahu wa'ta'ala describes himself in
the ninth verse of surah ml
the lord of the East and the West, none
is rightfully worshiped but he. So take
him as your sole disposer of your
affairs.
This word
ar
in the Arabic language has more than 12
meanings.
12 different meanings that are all
included in the general term.
Now
I want you to take in a principle
with respect to how the Quran uses its
arguments.
The way that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
structures the arguments of the Quran.
You see this book the Quran was revealed
to the Arabs in the time of the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
who believed in Allah in the linguistic
sense meaning they believed in a
creator. They were not atheists. They
believed in a creator who created
everything and sustains everything.
And they believed that he was one.
Not two, not three, not many.
They also believed that there was a
difference between the creator and the
creation. So they were not pantheists.
Hinduism for instance is a pantheus
religion.
They believe that everything is God and
God is everything and everywhere. This
is not what the belief was of the
idoltors of Mecca.
When the Quran was revealed to the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam. He
was not sent to a people that
disbelieved in a creator. They believed
that Allah existed.
And not only that, but they worshiped
Allah.
They worshiped Allah. They asked from
Allah. They begged from Allah. They made
dua to Allah. They believed in his
existence and that he was one and that
he was
sublime and unique.
and that he was the owner and possessor
of everything and he alone was the
creator. They believed that
the issue wasn't that they disbelieved
in that. The issue was that they
worshiped other than Allah because they
believed that these other things, these
idols that they worship, graves, trees,
stones, the sun, the moon, etc., they
believe that these things would
intercede on their behalf with Allah.
This is incredibly important. If we
don't understand this concept, it is
very easy to misunderstand the entirety
of the Quran's argument and structure.
When they worshiped al
for instance,
have we all heard of al right? It's in
the Quran.
Allet. Who is Allet? It was a man that
was considered to be a righteous man in
Mecca that used to take care of the
pilgrims when they came for Hajj every
year. And so he used to give lots of
charity and work very hard to serve the
pilgrims to the house of Allah every
year. Because of that they viewed him as
being someone close to Allah. When he
died, they turned his grave into an idol
that they worshiped. Why did they
worship al? Why did they worship al? It
wasn't because they believed al was the
creator.
It wasn't because they believed al was
the sustainer. No, they believe that
allet is a righteous man close to Allah
and if we get on his good side, he will
intercede on our behalf with Allah.
[Silence]
Allah tells us that the they worship
these idols because they believe these
idols would intercede on their behalf.
If you imagine with me modern
Catholicism, it's basic, it's based on
that
they worship and they pray to the saints
and the saints in turn will intercede
with with their creator on their
behalf. This is this is idolatry. This
is exactly what the pagan Arabs in the
time of our prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam believed.
It's very easy for us to mistake
our society today with theirs. And if we
do that, we'll misunderstand the
arguments of the Quran.
What do I mean? In the Quran, we see how
many u verses that refer to the creation
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Do you not
see that Allah has created the heavens
and created the earth and made the moon
in such a way and made the sun in such a
way and made the waves in the sea such a
way and all the creation that he made
etc etc. This is not an argument
for his existence
because they believed he existed.
This argument was all to set up what?
That you all believe that he is the only
one who did all of this. He is the only
creator, the only sustainer. Therefore,
why do you worship other than Allah?
That's the question. If you believe that
Allah is the only creator and sustainer
and all that you hope for lies in
Allah's hand and all that you fear lies
at Allah's ability, then why is it that
you worship other than Allah? This is
what they believed. This is what the
argument of the Quran is. Very rarely in
the Quran is the argument for Allah's
existence because this is something that
everyone believes. 99% of humanity
believes this throughout all of
humankind.
Atheism in its truest form is incredibly
rare. Incredibly rare.
And so
often times because of our materialistic
society
we we look and we see that a lot of
people disbelieve in Allah's existence
say Allah that there is no creator and
so then we look at the Quran and we see
the way that it it structures it
arguments and we confuse that as being
an argument for Allah's existence. Yes,
it means Allah exists obviously.
But this is not what the argument is
building. The argument is building that
if you believe in Allah's existence and
that he alone is the creator and
sustainer and maintainer and he is the
sovereign king etc. then why do you
worship others alongside him?
Those things that cannot hear, cannot
see, they have no hands, they have no
feet. If a fly were to steal from them,
they couldn't retrieve from that fly.
They couldn't create a a a fly. If they
all collaborated to do so,
why do you worship other than Allah?
This is the argument of the Quran. For
this reason, the scholars, they say that
[Silence]
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. They say belief in
Allah alone and that he is the only
creator and only sustainer etc. This
necessitates logically
that we would worship only Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And so when you
understand that that is the argument of
the Quran in most of its places, you
then start to understand how the
arguments are presented. this verse
here, he says,
Then
[Silence]
can Allah
This is the dua dwa of all of the
prophets and messengers. This verse
verse number nine captures that argument
with in its abridged form and that is he
is the lord of the east and the west.
Now east and west the physical east and
west and where the sun rises and where
the sun sets but also east and west is
symbolic too right because the east
symbolizes creation and start and
beginning the beginning of of the day
the rising of the sun the start of
movement the the earth is is
in in darkness ness and then the sun
rises and suddenly people emerge from
their houses. The animals, the birds
start to sing. Everyone starts to move
and come alive and then the sun sets and
it's as if everything ends. Right? This
symbolism is what Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is intending here. He says
he is the lord
of the east and west and he is also
symbolizing with the east and west. He
is the one that starts life. He is the
one that gives death. He is the one that
brings guidance and he is the one that
mis misguides and takes takes people off
of his path as a punishment to them. He
subhanahu wa ta'ala is the bringer of
light. He is the lord of the east and
the west. Subhanah.
So when he establishes that he says
cut yourself off from all connections
except to Allah. Then he says
who is Allah? He is the Lord,
the owner, the sustainer, the king of
the east and the west.
Therefore,
none is rightfully worshiped with him.
So here this we have
what doesahillah
mean? It's it's amazing how
unclear
many people are with respect to the
meaning ofahillahill
say what isahillah
there's no god but Allah not correct
that is not the full meaning
ofahillahillahill
is not there's no creator but Allah if
that's the if if that was the epitome
and the extent of our prophet's dawah
they would have agreed with him. They
have no problem with that. There's no
creator but Allah, we already believe
that. That wasn't the issue of
contention. The point of contention was
if you believe Allah is the only
creator, then worship only Allah. Here
is where the contention took place. Here
is where they said no. Because now
you're saying that our forefathers were
wrong and we can't worship our idols and
the their idols was a was a big source
of pride for them and also a source of
there were other things attached to that
idolatry
economically
socially etc. It was entwined into
their culture and so they felt that they
had too much to lose by foregoing their
gods that they worshiped. And so
here Allah structures the argument. He
teaches the prophet sallall.aii
the basis of his argument. What is it?
Get them to confirm that Allah is the
only creator.
Now you necessitate from them logically
that he alone is to be worshiped. So he
says
for
[Silence]
Subhan,
he says, "The Lord of the heaven, the
east and the west, none is rightfully
worshiped but he." So take him as your
sole disposer of affairs. Take him Allah
as your sole disposer of affairs being
that those are his descriptions.
Subhanahu Wa'ta'ala. This is the meaning
ofahill
and its relationship. now shared with
belief in the existence of Allah. Now
this is what sets Islam aside from all
other religions.
Most religions believe in one unified
creator.
Right? The problem is they worship other
than that one creator. Islam is
different. Why? Because we worship Allah
alone without any partners.
And that is what separates Islam from
Judaism, from Christianity, from all of
the religions of the earth. That even if
they claim monotheism in practice, they
do not uphold strict monotheism. Only
Islam does this. And this is the
argument of our prophet. And not just
our prophet, but every single prophet
and messenger.
Allah says, "And we have never sent a
messenger before you except that his
message is is the center thrust of his
message is none is rightfully worshiped
but I so worship me." When you look at
the prophets and messengers in the
Quran, the way that their dawa is
structured, every one of them comes,
read,
you'll see that the prophets and
messengers, all of them come with the
same general statement, which is
[Silence]
Islam.
Subhanahu wa'tala.
Subhanahu waala. And
Foreham.